- This is the only home we have!
de la lutte contre l'apartheid
n'est plus. Desmond Tutu,
prix Nobel de la paix
pour la justice raciale
a fait de la lutte contre les
injustices et lan
son combat de vie.
Il était connu pour être
atigable défenseur
des droits de l'homme.
"Nous devons critiquer
non équitable ou immoral."
Il a consacré une grande ne gre
de sa vie à lutter contre
le régime d'oppression
la majorité noire.
En 19e en robe mauve
est devenu le premier archevêque
anglican noir du Cap
- We will be free!
All of us!
- Le pardon et la réconciliation
les Blancs et les Noirs
était son cheval de bataille.
- Black and White together!
- Tout comme son ami
Nelson Mandela, il n'a cessé
d'importuner les pouvoirs
et de l'équité.
Il s'est mê
au Parti de la libération
en Afrique du Sud, au pouvoir
"Ce gouvernemennt est pire
que celui de l'apartheid."
Il a d'ailleurs présidé
mission de vérité et de
réconciliation, une nécessité
pour lui afin de tournerciale.
Et son influence transcendaitlee
au Canada en 1984, il a demandé
au premier minister une poter us
sévère pour faciliter
l'abolition de l'apartheid :
cette rencontre a d'ailleurs été
e comme un tournant dans
la réponse internationale.evenu
le premier leaderdu Commonwealts
sanctions économiques contre
l'Afrique du Sud
Et les visites de l'archevêque
pour défendre ses causes se sont
Comme celle-ci au Parlement
ontari ou cette
rencontre avec le dalaï-lama
à Vancouver en 2004.
BOB RAE, ambassadeur
du Canada aux Nations unie plus
grands, je dois dire,personnells
grands hommes que j'ai jamais
rencontré. Un hoavant tout
un homme de joie. Il avait la
colère, naturellement, il était
contre l'injustice. Il a lutté
toute
- Et l de Desmond Tutu
ne s'est pas arrêté pas là.
Au fil des ans, il a mobilisé
sur la justice climatique,
se du Darfse du Darfse du Darfs,
servi de médiateur au Kenya
et offert son aide à G
Jusqu'au bout, il aura été
un homme de justice,
Ici Danielle Kadjo,